[Music]
no Tyler one's story has always been
about defying expectations but his rapid
chest climbed to 1,400 rating an insane
achievement in so short a time has even
the experts flumed in 2 months of
playing time Tyler 1 has played 40 to 50
rapid chess games every single day he
has stopped streaming his puzzles rating
is
2500 now that he's crested 1400 rating
in Rapid chess which puts him at about
the rank of the average tournament
player we had to take a look at Tyler's
Journey not on summoner's Rift but on
the chessboard holy bro he's 1. that's
[Music]
insane all right guys I love covering
stories like these for you so if you
enjoy it tooo why not show us by liking
the video subscribing to the channel and
ringing the notification Bell if you
haven't already okay so get this on
September 15th that's 26 days ago Tyler
1 played his last League of Legends game
on stream and he hasn't streamed since
so like you had to deal with the
ghosting scum every game you going to
deal with if your dog piss thing
teammates on top of that thank God if
nobody's not win trading boosting or
account sharing that was aing Vibe
killer I'm not going to lie this was a
disaster we should have just got off
after the blitz chess we'll be live
tomorrow um not sure what time is though
he didn't go live the next day like he
said or any day since but that doesn't
mean he hasn't been grinding Tyler one
started playing chess back in early July
and both back then and now he mostly
plays rapid chess which on chess.com
means 10minute time controls per player
on July 18th Tyler one played 18 games
of Rapid chesson chess.com and the next
next day he logged back in got to 367
rating and then immediately suffered a
12-game losing streak before slowly
slipping down towards 2 later that month
he competed in POG Champs 5 which is a
rapid chess tournament for streamers and
ultimately lost to xqc
check
checkm wow wow that was good that strong
look at you you're pale you look like a
ghostb that can't be healthy you weigh
75 lbs actually you see yes you beat me
this time you won't by the way you will
not go to simis you are terrible by the
way no no character aside you are
actually terrible he's right he's right
he's right the guy just couldn't stop
playing chess and in early August that
usually looked like about 10 games of
Chess a day with maybe some bullet or
Blitz thrown into the usual assortment
of Rapid chess but on August 5th after
he had already been eliminated from POG
Champs Tyler 1 played 37 games of Rapid
chess and nearly climbed back to his
Peak rating from July now that volume is
the rule not the exception and since he
stopped streaming he's become even more
consistent he passed xqc's rating in
mid-september and he pointed out in one
of his last few streams that he feels
like being on stream hurts his
performance I can't play on stream I
suck I swear to God I'm not as bad I
play on stream and I literally can't
focus I can't function I can't play I
lose every time on stream and the dude
just keeps grinding after hitting 14400
rating a few days ago on October 9th
Tyler 1 played 66 games of Rapid chess
while his rating fell 100 points to
about 1,300 then yesterday while I was
writing this thing he had played 30
Games before my workday was even done
1,400 rating means that Tyler 1 is
already in the top 6% of Rapid chess
players on chess.com but remember he
didn't eventually get here he basically
got here in 2 and 1/2 months and the
chess Community is taking note chess
International Master Levy Rosman also
known as Gotham chess has focused a few
videos on Tyler's climb most of you are
going to look introspectively upon
yourselves after seeing what I have to
show you today and based on his far more
authoritative analysis Tyler might
actually have the knack for this like he
might actually be good at this thing and
he might still have a long way to go so
his opponent goes oh my Pawn is hanging
I got to defend
it Tyler one doesn't need a second
chance and his conversion here clinical
his games are so wild like you have got
to bury this man into the ground to beat
him because he's winning these absurd
back and forth games but they're they
make sense like they make sense he's
defending well he's figh fighting back
from unpleasant positions and he's
taking his chances when presented this
is one of the most insane stories i' I
I'm telling you that I have ever seen
now the final question many of us might
consider at this point instinctively is
when does this end when does Tyler 1
return to his stream you know the thing
that he does full-time most of the time
we don't have a definite date or time
and it's Tyler W so who knows but one of
the last chess streams that he did
uploaded to his YouTube Channel May hold
the answer dude I need 2,000 rating dude
I can get 2,000 rating listen once I get
200,000 rating I'll quit I'll be happy
at 2K rating hey how am I impatient dude
if I play I'm spamming games bro all
these GM players have 50 billion games I
can can I can do that in a month bro so
maybe he'll grind until he has as many
games as chess Grandmaster Magnus
Carlson or maybe he'll grind until he
actually hits 2K rating or maybe neither
will happen but 2,000 rating is
considered an expert level player on
chess.com it's the 99.9th percentile of
players in Rapid chess and there are
about 13,000 accounts above that rank it
takes most people years to climb from
1,000 to 2,000 and this guy is just
getting started listen some rating
systems work a bit differently but
getting 2,000 rating on chess.com B
would be an achievement for anyone so if
Tyler one could do it ever it would be
huge if he could do it within a year it
would basically be Unthinkable but
listen this is Tyler one we're talking
about the guy just seems to go from win
to win while honing both body and mind
he's no stranger to devoting himself to
the Grind Tyler one hit Challenger
playing every role in League of Legends
after all before that he managed to turn
his toxic raging into a remarkable
Redemption story so frankly it feels
hard to bet against the guy he's a true
renaissance man and I believe that he
can do it I think Tyler can hit 2K
rating call me crazy if you want and if
he does I hope xqc will agree to play a
few games against him so that they can
take each other's measure again maybe
that's not enough of a reason for you to
believe in Tyler though so let me add
something else to the mix while League
of Legends and chess might have strategy
in common I think there's a really key
difference like I said both games do
involve strategy but there's plenty of
random in League at most times
and especially now that I get why Tyler
might want to avoid it sometimes listen
I can't prove that this whole chess
thing is a reaction to his experiences
with League of Legends that's just a
theory I guess but I do want to argue
this while League of Legends has been
part of Tyler's life for a while chess
offers him something that League just
never can and that's when the game ends
and you lost Tyler can be 100% sure in
chess that it was his fault chess puts
Tyler fully in control of his own
destiny and for someone who has played
quite a bit of League that has to be a
little refreshing right and listen I
think we can be forgiven for not
assuming that this man would be the best
chess player but if he hits 2K rating I
will be so happy to be proven wrong
nobody is shoving beads up their ass to
get an advantage in or excuse me a chest
right no way right the squirrels are
going ham but I realize that they're
also under deadline they always seem
slightly call off God don't they like
whatever system squirrels use can't be
working that well I mean the lack of
calendars is also is like yeah no
language no unifying culture it was like
28° last week and then I walk out my
door this morning and it's like 8 like I
don't feel like any squirrel system kind
of count for that